[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté vous avez réuni vent nous une
quantité de produits c'est joli c'est
coloré c'est pas cher du tout c'est pas
cher du labrador des choses très bon
marché et ça fait un peu pas
extraordinaire et qu'est ce que c'est un
pot-au-feu breton vous allez quitter vos
landes de gascogne pour une fois non
parce que ça y ressemble
on va améliorer un petit peu avec une
pluie de touche de quelque chose non
plus alors le breton la bretagne a plein
de mer tout autour le sinon à landiras
du poisson pas du tout a dit pas du tout
y a pas du tout de pression il n'y a que
de la viande et de légumes
alors c'est une recette de la bretagne
profonde journal alors qu'est ce qu'il
vous faut
eh bien nous fait un show ou celui-là il
est super une faute elle avait une fois
vous voulez un bouquet garni d'or du
thème des percées du laurier des
carottes des oignons du poireau des
pruneaux arrière à des pruneaux ces
petites touches exit voilà donc un peu
dans l'armagnac
ça vous n'avez pas résisté pas du tout
c'est la note du sud-ouest s'arrête
pendant ce week-end face de poudre alors
la céda farine farid de sa réserve
je l'avais jamais si bien si on est avec
ça qu'on fait les galettes bretonnes
traditionnelles crêpes
j'espère à manger parce que ça pète ça
existe et oui je sais pas tout et il
faut toujours découvrir quelque chose et
veut voir dans ce day qu'il souhaite
avec ce pack walla du corian wimereux la
coriandre de l'accord viande voilà des
bulles girofle fourie le poireau je sais
pas si je les vivants je leur dis oui
des pommes de terre et lune innoviandes
alors les viandes nous avons quoi là
lorsque le jeune et de boeuf cents us
voilà ensuite ça c'est le plat de côtes
avec os bien entendu on veut pas faire
autrement
ça c'est comme un poteau fait normal et
ça c'est du un jarret de porc que vous
avez réincarnation un gamin jo 2016
alors autrement dit c'est un petit
mélange entre un pot-au-feu traditionnel
et un petit salé traditionnel avec une
petite note régional régional de la
bretagne
alors je ne veux pas que vous avez caché
la 9 à 9
on va voir pourquoi mais pour commencer
qu est ce qu elle plus l'horreur par
quoi faut-il faire cuire les viandes
dans de l'eau un petit peu salée l'appel
en premier à soissons qu'une importance
parce que c'est aussi leur laine en
cuisson bruit pour tout le monde pour
tout lé bien vous avez salerno à l'avant
roland
alors là je vais salle et il faut la
salle et avait dû ciel de guérande le
guérandais bien entendu marais salants
de la bretagne au sud de la bretagne
la voilà bon endroit vrai et je vais
mettre mes viande alors le jardin de
danse le cas majorité des passerelles et
les deux à l'avant celui là attention
vérité il a glissé vous l'avez des
salles et un peu non parce que c'est lui
seul à ses demi-soeurs musique pour me
crosse alors là on va y mettre
l'oignon avait les clous de girofle oui
mais c'est parce qu'il avait la figure
je pense que vous voudriez prix de
celles réunies
altro restez chez vous n'avez pas m oui
martin massé grand oui voilà ea pourra
faire le bouquet garni en avion la
flèche d énergie là leur bouquet garni
le persil bien entendu saverne a dû aux
lecteurs la wii tout frais ça sent bon
la le laurier les lauriers de woodside
de très bien
aux ficelles de tours et voilà la livre
et je couvre en la ceinture parce que ça
c'est beau coupé sur les légumes
maintenant ça va être tout démoli de
légumes persuadé que là on va leur dire
y'a qu'ça crise au moins une heure comme
ça pour commencer on même laverda c'est
même bien passé et nous allons pouvoir
faire alors quoi
la spécialité bretonne voilà qu'est ce
qu'il vous faut rappeler nous un petit
peu là comment l'appeler ligne a des bon
bouillon
oui vous êtes des produits halal dans
son arrogance lorsque celui-là il est
parfait il nous faut les pruneaux qui
ont macéré dans under maniaque sa peau
le fameux farine de sarrasin
oui la crème fraîche du lait du sel du
poivre bien entendu des pruneaux ce 2e
et pierre et qu'est ce qu'elle soit là
j'ai oublié de les mettre je voulais
mettre ce sont les grilles arguant alors
que je vais mettre dans le bouillon qui
s'enlève est dans l'union mais je n'ai
pas trop de temps en temps c'est pas
grave
voilà si jamais trop tard pour bien
faire je l'avais si vous prenez la
famille vous ouvre ses bras syfy oui
voilà
très bien alors alors fini pour la core
io et leïla et
voilà là j'ai fait fendre de 5 g de
beurre ah oui alors je mets ma farine
ici je vais faire un puits là c'est à
peu près 500 g de farine maladie et
drôle ce farine et les crèches privées
quand on avait besoin de la bretagne on
sait comment c'est ça fait des galettes
délicieuse voilà un peu marron mais
délicieuse dès les 5 g de beurre que je
mets juste vendu oui là on va atteindre
alors là je met du sel et du poivre
moi j'essaie de toujours oui et je
poivre tout chaud parce qu'il faut que
ça eu du goût quand même et la n141 17
ans et pas de ça donc c'est pour ça il
faut que ces histoires je vais y casser
2e entière voilà je vais tout vient tous
avaient les mêmes bien entendu parce
qu'ils sont quand même la spree man le
plus comment exactement les pins second
versant ce conseil mais ça quand même
peut-être pas de suffit en fait relié
dans cette terrible il assure que non la
rajouter quelque chose alors là je vais
mettre ma crème fraîche
vous n'êtes pas content vous allez
maintenant m vous la met pourtant
déchire craps à la moitié la moitié du
cuir la paix oui a recueilli 2 et à la
limite et dan coats aggravant une plus à
l'est non là ça qui va non seulement
c'est mon devoir aujourd'hui alors je
vais rajouter un petit peu de lait oui
stoppons rajoutera près et on retourne
bien entendu d'être mauvais ça être
parce qu'il faut que ça se paye un peu
importe pour le régime à sa sueur alors
là je vais rajouter du bouillon le
bouillon de viande pour finir il ya
voilà verser un tout petit peu favorisés
faire même des plus secs là de ce côté
on va faire avec ça un peu plus là stop
il vaut mieux en remettre que la leçon
qui devient la wii ah oui parce que s'il
est trop liquide non mais là il faut
mettre la moitié
je vais rajouter un petit peu de lait
elle va soulager commence-t-elle
elle commence à prendre une substance
qui me paraît bien
j'ai l'impression ne loupe jamais rien
mais il ya une certaine pattes qui a été
dans un bêtisier vous souvenir c'est
pour ça que je vais t'en sur ma voix va
l'avoir
alors à vous paraît bon et les pruneaux
de vous servir à quoi
alors maintenant je vais me dis soyez un
petit peu je fais le ménage un petit peu
mes mains oui parce que là ça cette
école paraît bien entendu puisque la
pâte et les mollets oui l'aspect c'est
pas terrible pour koné
mais le goût on va voir après écoute et
alors c'est bruno vous les avez quoi
faites vous avez dénoyautées évidemment
c'est bruno voilà on les des noyaux tout
simplement un conteur un coupé en deux
on les a bien fait chanter pour giggs
est lauréate vous enlevez qui sont prêts
à nous fatiguer parce que pour vous
montrer voilà rentré qu'on peut le faire
voilà voilà
et puis vous entendez ça t'en servir à
nous débrouiller et on mélange est
ensuite alors là on cite je suis
curieuse de voir ce qui va se passer
allez voir là et je vais rouler le
bouder dans un torchon
je suis curieuse de voir comment à bout
d un bouddha sans viande à c'est quand
même un lien très particulier
oui ça c'est un pot-au-feu aussi alors
passé leur tour
les bretons et non pas un mets cuisinés
que nous donc ça c'est vraiment mauvais
alors après là alors on fait on écrase
france est moins facile que ça en a
l'air comme lui de faire le beau dans la
vallée voilà seul et bien un tour qui
leur viennent allonger
voilà voilà voilà ça vient là comme il
faut aller et on roule très bien parfait
et on va fixer en laissant deux maires
des deux côtés j'y vais je fis c'est
louis petit ne vous fait le pendant ce
temps je voudrais me suis un petit peu
plus difficile il faudrait doubler
et puis je vous donne là l'autre social
est à nous deux on va faire très vite et
très bien
allez hop un petit tour
et c'est bon et ensuite comment est-ce
qu'on va accueillir cette affaire c'est
à dire c'est à dire on va mettre dans le
bouillon c'est comme ça que ça va donner
du goût là alors le bouillon saïfi où il
ya la viande de lait coûte de girofle le
bouquet garni la sellerie vous allez les
coriande alors aux médecins je vous
garde à petit sur cinq ans ce petit
sortir la voilà oui mais on va sortir et
je vais mettre de légumes et barre est
maintenant vous allez ajouter alors les
carottes entier carottes sont cuites
dans son cloud avant cuire les carottes
on me dit que vous vouliez pas mal de la
fin il y en a trois là ça suffit oui
parce que ça fait d'armes c'est une
beauté dans le force
bon alors il faut du légume les pommes
de terre aussi oui et le chou le céleri
en hadj amine en roumanie 2-3 plus larbi
toutes les promoteurs de toute façon
inutile de leur mari non non non non pas
pour le potage ont fait pas que me
blanchir du show c'est un pêché ça on
digère moi je digère et moi tout le
monde mettra oui n'oublions pas les
poires de mettre un petit peu de new
york
je vais remettre de l'eau parce que il y
en a pas c'est un peu lourd non là les
poireaux l'oignon vous aviez dix
l'amitié pas la peine d'en rajouter
là je pars ce qui a tout il ya juste de
l'eau à rajouter pour que ça baigne dans
l'eau et c'est tout et on va laisser
cuire 1 tout ça gentiment une bonne
heure non quand même bien assez bien
tassés irda c'est là va remettre de
l'eau voilà et on attendra aussi à peu
près une heure une heure une heure et
demie on a mis les 3 vient de dans le
plat voilà le jarret de porc le jarret
de beurre les légumes
voyez le chou les carottes les navets
tout bien sûr à part le bouillon et
maintenant et ici alors là j'ai voir ce
qui se passe là deux heures à on va
dérouler notre le show cars
ça s'appelle et oui ça veut dire sarine
aux bretons marina breton
là est la ans et l'inertie que les
athéniens sa tenir
mais savez c'est mignon comme tout il
est classé très peu peuple voilà
mais c'est dur plus tôt ces fermes et
bien c'est joli comme tout cas là vous
savez ça comment vous le découper en
alors ça c'est le pen ça remplace que
passe à remplacer le perdre c'est assez
ringard c'est pas joli somme est tout à
fait libre à regarder ça et retrouve les
pruneaux dedans et puis ça sent très bon
vin se vend encore une belle tranche
voilà est alors aux marges la viande le
chou le bouillon et puis le perdre et on
arrive à bien le fameux fax avec le
bouillon voilà parce que c'est dur c'est
très très bon ben et appétissants et
voilà une excellente variante de la
potée bourguignonne ou de vos potos
finlandais voilà ça change alors pour
vous tous une occasion d'essayer quelque
chose d'un peu différent vraiment très
facile à faire pas cher ça va de soi
déshabillez vous ne serez pas déçus au
revoir bientôt
bon appétit et à bientôt
[Musique]